G1
[Música]
e
eu não queria estar aqui
o ou melhor
eu não planejei estar aqui
e eu nunca imaginei tudo isso que tá
acontecendo na minha vida nesse momento
e até porque
e quando você estoura
e em alguma profissão
o famoso sucesso
existe várias frases de efeito como
Quem corre mais que você vai conseguir
eu sabia que eu conseguiria chegar até
aqui
é como fosse uma profetização
o e atrelado a planejamento planejamento
que venhamos e convenhamos
se você não acha
o que se esse planejamento fosse
verídico pelo menos grande parte da
população brasileira
eu teria sucesso
e o ao menos dignidade
quem é
é mas não é isso que você escuta por aí
normalmente
e sempre atrelam
e a falta de coragem
a perseverança
a querer
e pensa comigo entre nós aqui olha só
a perseverança coragem e ocorrer vai
dizer que isso não é o que o povo
brasileiro mais tem
Olá meu nome é João diamante
a sua filha de mãe solo tenho 30 anos
hoje eu vou te contar como descobrir
isso da maneira mais dura possível
eu venho do Nordeste Bahia
eu desenvolvi minha vida inteira dentro
de uma comunidade no Rio de Janeiro no
Complexo do Andaraí Zona Norte
e ainda muito novo AOS 7 anos de idade
troquei os brinquedos por panelas as aba
pães e uma padaria perto da minha casa
realidade de muitos jovens e pessoas que
vivem em periferias e favelas EA margem
e eu só consegui mudar essa realidade
e quando eu fui para a Marinha do Brasil
o lugar que passei cinco anos da minha
vida
eu tive a oportunidade de estudar
fiz um curso de técnico de nutrição e
dietética
e logo após foi para faculdade
de gastronomia ensino superior e sabe
porque eu consegui através de políticas
públicas de qualidade e que
verdadeiramente vai impactar na vida de
qualquer um
bom
e depois de todas esse conhecimento eu
fiquei entre os três melhores alunos da
faculdade e consegui parar saber aonde
na França
e no jardim de Luxemburgo
e na Torre Eiffel um dos melhores
restaurantes do mundo
é só que pensa que para você que foi
fácil não foi não mas esse a história de
correr querer já tá no sangue de
qualquer brasileiro então cheguei lá eu
foquei
eu estudei
e eu voluir e sabe qual é a minha maior
dificuldade a língua
e até porque eu não falava nem tão bem o
português assim você imagina o francês
E aí então pelo momento eu conto entrei
muito e consegui ultrapassar essa
barreira da língua consegui atuar em
várias áreas do restaurante
Ah e assim
verdadeiramente evoluir
Ah e só assim eu percebi que a arte que
a cultura EA educação
é só são as únicas formas formas
realmente
mágica para mudar a vida de qualquer um
o perdão dessa ideia
e eu construir um projeto que se chama
diamante na cozinha projeto social
diamante na cozinha O que é o diamante
na cozinha
Esse é um projeto social que você
utiliza a gastronomia como ferramenta
é mas tem uma coisa em comum como todos
os projetos que o objetivo é através da
cultura da arte e da educação
incluir inserir e dar oportunidade
e o projeto diamante na cozinha
e ele acontece em 3 meses
e o aluno entra desde
plantar cultivar e colher
aprendendo todas as áreas da cozinha ou
da Gastronomia assim mais amplo
e ele aprende cozinha quente cozinha
fria
Panificação
Confeitaria
empreendedorismo entre outras matérias
que tem no setor
é mas não é só a parte teórica EA parte
prática que o diamante na cozinha incide
em compartilhar com os alunos e sim
encorajá-los
empoderá-los inseri-las dentro de uma
sociedade que sempre sempre tende a
separá-los
até porque no início do curso
muitos alunos relatam assim chefe
e eu corro muito
e eu todo dia acordo 5 horas da manhã
e eu todo dia vou dormir meia-noite
Ah e nada na minha vida Acontece o que
que tá acontecendo que eu tô fazendo de
errados
E aí eu perguntei assim uma vez vou
perguntar para vocês
A que horas você estuda
A que horas você adquirir conhecimento
hoje e que horas você evolui
verdadeiramente
é porque o sistema
E aí para te boicotar todo momento
Ah e só depois deles adquire todo o
conhecimento que o diamante na cozinha
entregou
e ele percebe chefe realmente agora
eu sou outra pessoa eu tenho vida eu
entro eu saio de onde eu quiser e como
quiser
e o que não só realmente o aprendizado
teórico da coisa e sim o empoderamento a
certeza que você tá ali realmente vai
desenvolver um trabalho incrível que
você pode a confiança
Oi e a única Fórmula Mágica que existe
para isso acontecer
a educação
Oi e a educação
atrelada as oportunidades liberta
e a partir daí sim
você pode falar que ocorrer
o que o acordar 5 horas da manhã
o tio e dormir meia-noite
e vai fazer a diferença
e até porque
e quantas pessoas
não fazem isso
ó e vai fazer diferença sabe por quê e o
que você já tem o básico
é o mínimo a dignidade conhecimento
O que é dignidade
o empoderamento
Ah e só a partir daí ele se liberta
Oi e aí
e você pode até a sonhar
a entrar uma lista da revista Forbes a
Bethany
O que é uma revista e é uma parte da
revista que classificam jovens com menos
de 30 anos promissores no Brasil
a onde eu
consegui entrar
eu sou embaixador do Instituto e de BR
Instituto identidade do Brasil que briga
por igualdade racial
é a minha vida
eu tinha tudo para dar errado
e aos olhos da população brasileira
O Nordestino
o preto
o pobre
o e favelado
E aí
é mas mostra
o que através da educação
cultura e da arte
atrelada a oportunidade você consegue
mudar
se o seu destino e o destino de qualquer
um
o e consegue sonhar
o
almejado sucesso
e até porque o que é sucesso para você
o sucesso para mim
e foi sempre tentar garantir o básico
a gratidão
E aí